much of the time when the Zimmermann
telegram is discussed the focus is often
on the German American and British
reactions to it seldom does Mexico's
part in the whole incident get a mention
of what it intended to do which
obviously raises the question how did
Mexico react to the Zimmermann telegram
so just to let everyone know the
Zimmermann telegram was a diplomatic
cable sent to Mexico from Germany in
1917 as World War one was ravaging the
continent this message named after
Arthur Zimmermann the German foreign
minister gave German financial and
political support to Mexico should it
invade the United States it promised to
recognize Mexican ownership of Texas New
Mexico and Arizona but not California or
the rest of the territory the Mexico had
lost to the US in 1848 Mexico at this
point was to put it mildly not the most
stable state in the world and had been
fighting a bloody civil war for roughly
seven years and relations with the
United States were absolutely awful
as such the Mexican government under
President Burness Tianna Carranza turned
to Germany for whatever support again
given the us-mexican tensions the
Germans felt that sending the telegram
was worth a shot one problem the
diplomatic cable had to travel through
London before it could even cross the
Atlantic it was quickly intercepted and
decoded by the British who promptly told
everyone but the Germans could have
simply denied it right yes yet they
didn't and Zimmermann publicly declared
it to be real an American opinion
rapidly shifted from isolationism to
let's go squash the Germans yet before
it was publicly known Mexico had
received the telegram so what did they
think well Carranza didn't dismiss it
straight away and given his dislike for
the United States he asked his generals
how to wage war against it the generals
came to one conclusion
fighting a war with the US would be easy
winning it would be impossible the
reasons for their conclusions were thus
one the German offers of military aid
were basically meaningless Germany could
send some u-boats but their value would
be limited which meant that all they
could really do was send some advisors
to Germany was being blockaded by the
Royal Navy and so good luck getting any
of that promised cash three Mexico was
still fighting a civil war and war was a
multiple fronts seldom and well there
was no sense fight in the u.s. when
behind the front lines revolutionaries
would be trying to overthrow the
government for Mexico's economy couldn't
handle a major war the Civil War had
done little to affect Mexico's booming
oil industry but a blockade by the u.s.
Navy would have destroyed it completely
five even if all these problems could
have been avoided the United States
would have crushed Mexico anyway
you see before this the US had briefly
occupied Veracruz in 1914 after a
diplomatic incident and there was little
doubt that they could do it again but
for the whole country as such no action
was taken by Mexico because whilst
Carranza disliked the US he wasn't
suicidal nothing was settled on about
the Zimmermann telegram because for
Mexico there was nothing to be done
it couldn't have won the war and
ultimately its leaders could see that
Germany wanted Mexico to be little more
than a speed bump to slow down American
deployment to Europe I hope you enjoyed
this episode and thank you for watching
with extra thanks to my patreon
supporters which you can see on screen
and with an extra special thanks to
James Bissonnette David archaeologist
Ozark a flash Party Boyko Rob Waterhouse
Chris wicker Michael Reynolds Gustav
Swann David Silverman spinning three
plates
Maggie packs Kowski Christian check'
Anthony Beckett Ike Skye Chappell and
Winston Cawood
you